Okay.
We should be live here. Hello.
Let me real quick
make sure Twitch is working.
I probably need to set some more stuff
up. Um
This is fine for now. This is fine for
now.
Let's just do
me set my
What is wrong with this, man? This
should be
We should be live. Oh, there it goes.
There it goes.
Set the category software.
Game development.
Okay.
I'm happy with this.
Works on Restream. Yep, it works on
Restream.
Count access expired
on Twitch.
That seems really weird because we're
live on Twitch now, aren't we?
Hang on.
Let me fix that.
>> It's not the restream off.
I might have to just toggle it on and
back off again.
Be right back, guys. I just I messed
with Twitch real quick.
Uh I'll be back in a second. And we're
going to do like 4 hours of refactoring
today on stream.
Um it'll be somewhat entertaining and
definitely productive.